TODD GAGE: Good morning.
My name's Todd Gage.
I'm the Product Manager for
Persistent Disk and Local SSD.
I want to thank you all for
joining us here this morning,
especially at 9:00 AM after
a big party last night.
So here's what we're
here to talk about today.
We're going to talk a bit about
persistent disk, some best
practices, a little bit
about our future performance,
and then cover a whole bunch
of new features, which I'm
very excited to show you today.
So for those of
you who have been
going to any of the
storage sessions thus far,
you've probably seen this slide.
It gets a bit more
complicated every year,
a bit more like an
eye chart every year.
And so to help you out,
here's where we are.
We're looking in the storage
section under block storage,
and we're going to be talking
about persistent disk.
And Google Cloud Platform has
three block storage products,
local SSD, which is
physically attached,
physically resident
in the machine.
This is ephemeral storage.
If that machine goes
down, we don't guarantee
that that data remains.
However, there's also the
highest performance storage
we have because it is physically
resonant in the machine.
We have two flavors
of persistent disk.
Now these are designed to be
durable persistent storage.
And the two flavors, we have one
backed by standard hard drives,
and that's really for cost
effective, high volume storage,
and then one backed
by SSD, which
is for your high
performance storage needs.
I'm going to quickly talk
about just sort of overall PD.
Now, as I said, PD is a high
performance durable block
storage for any of
your virtual instances,
either on Google Kubernetes
Engine or Google Compute
Engine.
Presents itself as a
virtual SCSI device.
And it scales from one
gigabyte all the way up to 64T.
Persistent disk supports multi
reader in read only mode, which
we'll talk about
a bit in a moment;
snapshots, which, again,
we'll cover in a moment;
and scale, again,
going from one gig
to 64T with the ability to
grow while that disk is in use.
And as you've probably
heard throughout this week,
security is very, very
key component Google Cloud
Platform.
And so all of our data
is encrypted at rest
automatically either via Google
encryption keys or your own.
We see a couple common
patterns of behavior
with persistent disk.
This is the simplest.
This could be your basic
web server, WordPress,
anything like that where
you just have one volume,
one virtual machine.
Another common pattern is a
root disk and then some data.
This could be your
database instance, anything
where you have working data.
Again, not very complicated.
This is where things get
to be more interesting.
This could be a big
compute workload
where you have one data disk,
you put it in read only mode.
You shard out all
that work to workers.
And you don't actually have
to multiply record that data.
You just have all those
instances point at one disk.
And then finally,
something, again, we'll
talk about a bit more
in a bit is the ability
to synchronously
replicate data across two
zones with a new offering
that we're calling Regional
Persistent Disk.
So persistent disk snapshots
I mentioned a second ago.
Persistent disk snapshots are
used for a number of things.
One is just basic
backup of your data.
This data is critical
to your business.
You want to make
sure that you have it
around in case of future need.
Snapshots are of
great use for that.
Disaster recovery.
You want to insulate your
business against disaster.
You can take snapshots
that are stored in a GCS
multi-regional bucket,
and that ensures you
against the data
loss in any one zone.
And then finally, disk cloning.
Snapshots allow you to really
quickly replicate disks
across multiple
regions, multiple zones.
And the first disk is relatively
fast, and every disk after that
will be very, very fast.
Here's a couple examples
of snapshots in use.
On the left, we have
Volume 1 and you
see we are taking
snapshots at T1 through T4.
Each of those snapshots
is a point in time,
but it's also incremental,
so you're only
storing the additional
data that you need
from the previous snapshot.
Now on the right,
you see this user
is taking a copy of
Volume 1 at Time 2,
and then also doing disk
cloning at the bottom,
making three copies
of Volume 1 at Time 4,
potentially for use across
three different machines.
Couple of best practices
to go through this morning.
One thing I didn't
mention earlier
but you might have
read on the slide
is that persistent disk
gives you maximum performance
without the need
for RAID or striping
across multiple volumes.
Persistent disk
performance is exclusively
tied to the disk
size, so we give you
an allocation of I/O per
gigabyte and bandwidth
per gigabyte that increases
linearly up to the bandwidth
caps, or up to the caps.
So unlike other platforms
you may have seen,
there's no additional need to
add volumes for performance.
Also, we really suggest
you look at both your I/O
size and queue depths.
So for high IOPS workloads, we
suggest 16 kilobyte block sizes
or smaller, and larger
I/O queue depths,
which really help performance
at those lower block sizes.
Specifically, for high I/O,
we suggest a queue depth of 1
for every 400-800 IOPS.
Now on the other side, on
high throughput workloads,
we suggest block sizes
of 256K or larger
and enabling the read
ahead cache in the OS.
Finally, we really
suggest aligning your I/O
to 4K boundaries.
What you see on the
right is an example of 6K
writes at the top, how
persistent disk sees this
in the middle, and then
how it's actually written
to the volume on the bottom.
And what's a little
less apparent
is that for every 6K
write, you actually
have to touch two blocks.
So you're effectively
doing 30% more disk access
for the same amount of
traffic, where if you just
aligned your rights
to four 4K boundaries,
you can save those
extra disk accesses.
I'm now very excited to share
with you some announcements,
starting with performance.
Performance is the thing
that we hear the most
about from our customers.
It's consistent in literally
every customer conversation,
and it's something that we're
always focused on improving.
As I said earlier, persistence
disk comes in two flavors.
We have standard
persistent disk backed
by HDD and SSD persistent disk.
And then you can really see the
stark difference in performance
here.
SSD doubles the IOPS
on the right side
and is more than an order of
magnitude faster on reads.
One thing to note, as I
say in the corner here,
this does require machines
with 32 vCPUs or larger
on the SSD side to
achieve these IOPS.
And now I'm very, very excited
to announce a 50% improvement
in read performance for PD SSD.
This increases our
read IOPS to 60,000
and our bandwidth
to 1.2 gigabytes.
Now some lucky few of
you may have already seen
this performance in production.
But if you haven't, don't worry.
It will be rolling
out to all of PD SSD
over the next couple of weeks,
and I'm very, very excited
to see people take
advantage of it.
Now, as I said, we're always
working on performance,
and we're not stopping there.
So we do have something
in our performance labs
that we're working on.
And this is a number of changes
kind of baked in together.
But as you can see, we're
getting all the way up
to 100K IOPS and 1.6
gigabytes of bandwidth.
And the most
exciting thing for us
is how that translates into
real world performance.
On the right-hand
side, you can see
we did some read-only
benchmarking against Postgres
and Aerospike and saw
almost a 30% improvement
on Postgres and over a 40%
improvement on Aerospike.
Now, as I mentioned,
in the lab there's
a couple of different
changes going on.
But as we dug into
this, it looks
like that performance change is
primarily driven by the IOPS.
And we're really
excited to get this out.
No promises yet,
but as I said, it's
something we're
actively working on.
Now, earlier I mentioned
regional persistent disk,
and now I'd like to talk about
it in a little bit more detail.
So regional persistent
disk presents itself
as a singular persistent
disk to your virtual machine.
However, on the back
end, it is synchronously
replicated across two zones.
Regional persistent
disk works either
with Google Kubernetes Engine
or Google Compute Engine
and allows you a single
disk for high availability.
One thing to note,
regional persistent disk
has all the performance
of a persistent disk
other than right bandwidth.
Right bandwidth is
halved because you're
writing the data to two places,
but otherwise the performance
is exactly the same.
So regional
persistent disk really
provides you a building
block for building
either disaster recovery
solutions or high availability
solutions, depending on what
you need for your business.
It improves durability
and availability.
And we've really spent time
building this for mission
critical applications.
In fact, for any of you
that are using Cloud SQL's
high availability
configuration, that
is backed by regional
persistent disk,
and it has been a very
successful product for us.
This, as I note, is in beta
and it's available today.
You can just go to your
instance, open a new disk,
and you will see
something like this.
So this is the new UI.
You can replicate this
disk within a region.
That changes the zone dropdown.
And instead of zone
it's now zones,
and you're able to select up
to two zones in that region.
So it's very, very
straightforward to set up,
almost as easy as setting
up a normal persistent disk,
but automatically
gets you replication
across these two zones.
And now to show you
a little bit more
about regional persistent
disk in practice,
I'd like to introduce Saad Ali.
He's the tech lead for Google
Kubernetes Engine Storage.
SAAD ALI: All right.
Thank you very much, Todd.
So my name is Saad Ali.
I'm tech lead of GKE storage,
and I'm really, really excited
about this regional
persistent disk feature.
Let me talk a little
bit about it today.
So like Todd mentioned,
regional persistent disks
are a great building block
for building HA applications.
It'll automatically handle
any storage level failures.
It'll automatically
failover with lower latency.
But it'll be invisible
to you as an end user.
But what happens if you
have VM level failure,
you have zonal failures and
the VMs become unavailable?
Normally you'd have an outage
until somebody on your team
notices and goes in and manually
moves that workload over.
It's nice that you have the
replication across zones,
but you still require
manual intervention in order
to make your application HA.
Or you could build
custom tooling
that will go ahead and
monitor the virtual machines,
monitor your application and
do the failover manually.
But that's a lot of
complicated tooling.
Wouldn't it be nice if there was
something that did this for you
Automatically
Kubernetes Engine.
Google Kubernetes Engine handles
all of this for you already.
By a show of hands,
how many of you
are familiar with Kubernetes?
That's what I like to see.
And how many of you use GKE?
Awesome.
So with GKE, we do node level
health monitoring already
for you.
And we automatically
will move your workloads
if we detect that the
node is unhealthy.
And along with your workloads,
we'll move your storage.
You don't have to do a thing.
So the next question
is, how do you actually
use this in Kubernetes?
If you're familiar
with Kubernetes,
you've probably already seen
the storage class API object.
It enables Kubernetes
cluster administrators
to specify a template for
provisioning new volumes.
So when you as an end
user want to use storage,
you specify a storage class in
your persistent volume object,
and a new volume
gets provisioned
using that template.
So to enable
automatic provisioning
of regional persistent
disks, all you have to do
is add a couple
of new parameters
to your storage class.
One is the replication
type to indicate
that you want a regional
persistent disk,
and the second is
zones to indicate
which zones you want your
persistent disk to be
replicated in.
And then Kubernetes
will automatically
provision a new regional
persistent disk for you,
and you'll use it in
exactly the same way
you're used to using persistent
volumes in Kubernetes today.
So now let's take a look at how
it's going to work in practice.
So imagine you have two zones,
and each has a single zone.
And you have a workload that's
running on the node in Zone 1,
and a replicated disk is
attached to that workload.
But now Zone 1 suffers
some sort of failure
and the node in Zone 1
is no longer available.
Kubernetes is automatically
going to detect this,
and it's going to terminate
your app from the unhealthy zone
and prepare it for moving.
And it'll automatically
detach the volume
from the node in the
first zone and attach it
to the healthy node
in the second zone,
and move your
workload over as well.
And your stateful
service basically
automatically heals
from a zonal failure
without you having
to intervene at all.
You didn't have to
write custom tooling.
You didn't have to do
any manual intervention.
That's the beauty of
regional persistent disks.
So regional persistent disks
are available as a beta feature
starting with Kubernetes 110.
Please try it out
and let us know what
you think Thank you very much.
Back to you, Todd.
TODD GAGE: Thank you, Saad.
So I realize I didn't
cover one key thing
about regional
persistent disk, which
is it is available in both
flavors of persistent disk.
You can do regional
persistent disk
or standard persistent disk or
SSD persistent disk depending
on your business need.
I now want to talk about
regional snapshots.
Regional snapshots allow
users, for the first time,
to specify the locations
that their snapshots land in.
As I mentioned earlier today,
snapshots automatically
get recorded in a GCS
multi-regional bucket.
And going forward, users will
be able to select whether they
wish a region or
multi-regional bucket,
and then can select any
region or multi-region
within the Google network.
This really provides
users a choice
between whether they want
insulation against disaster
recovery or data
residency, where you really
need the data to stay
in a single location
for legal or regulatory reasons.
This also, for the
first time, means
that snapshots
are going to begin
to charge for network transit.
And so there's also a
cost effective play here,
where if you want to
avoid network transit,
you can keep those snapshots
exactly where the disk is,
and all you pay
for is the storage
you're paying for today.
If you have any interest
in this whatsoever,
please email
pdinterest@google.com
and I'll be very,
very happy to share
with you more information.
Here's an example of what
this looks like in practice.
I'm going to highlight the
key features for you here.
On the left-hand side,
we see that we're
setting up a regional snapshot.
And I've selected
the default, which
is just have the snapshot reside
in the exact same location
as the disk.
As I said earlier,
this is a setup
we see fairly commonly for
data residency, data locality
concerns, and/or to
drive costs down.
On the right, you
can see I'm selecting
a multi-regional bucket and
moving the data to the EU.
And this would be, again,
for disaster recovery.
Or, if I know that
I need to replicate
that disk multiple times
in the EU in the future,
I can write that data to the EU
once and then replicate locally
many, many times, again, for
cost savings on the network
transit.
Your snapshot list will
also begin to change.
And there is a new
column here for location.
It's the second column there.
It just shows you where
these snapshots reside,
or where the people need
snapshot management tools.
And this will really help you
find all of your snapshots
based on location
using the filter.
Another exciting
feature for snapshots
I'm happy to talk about
is snapshot scheduling.
Snapshot scheduling provides
lifecycle management
for snapshots from
creation to deletion.
You can schedule per
hour, by day, or by week.
It supports snapshot locality.
And again, if this is
something that's of interest,
please email
pdinterest@google.com.
And here's an example of
setting up a daily schedule.
And you can see selected
a regional bucket.
But then, down in the
frequency, selected every day
at 3 o'clock.
So this snapshot will kick
off in that hour once a day.
And then all of those snapshots
will be deleted automatically
14 days later.
In this instance, I'm
setting up a weekly schedule.
And as you see, I'm specifying
the day of the week,
and then which hour of that day
I want the snapshot created.
Now, what you can't see is
on the bottom of the screen
there's still the
auto delete row.
It just is off the screen.
But every snapshot schedule
includes an audio deletion
policy.
I'm not going to show you
the hourly schedule today,
but it's very much in
line with these two.
However, what I will
show you is how you
attach a schedule to a disk.
Now, at the top when
you select the disk,
every disk today can only
have one attached schedule.
However, you can use a
schedule for many, many disks.
So if you know that you
have some data that you want
to back up every
day, some data you
want to back up every week--
don't have monthly yet,
but it's in the works--
or every hour, then you can set
up those schedules singularly,
and then attach that
to all the data disks
that it applies to
so you don't have
to manage many, many schedules.
So again, if you have any
questions about anything
that you've seen today, please
email pdinterest@google.com.
That's for alpha signups,
questions about best practices,
or any other things
you would like to know.